on rio's famous sugarloaf mountain
they're trying to restore the forest
below to what it used to be
the atlantic forest is a kind of
rainforest like the amazon biologist
roberto guimaraes de souza is overseeing
a project to regrow the area with native
trees
so in the amazon we saw deforestation
here there seems to be regrowth and
reforestation it's a matter of climatic
adaptation for us we need to have our
forests restored so it's not just an
issue of the carbon that is stored here
as other issues as well with the forest
it's a matter of survival for us
because we have many natural disasters
in rio
people from the communities up in the
mountains they usually
lose their houses when it rains
it's happening already for the last few
years we've suffered in the summer with
too much rain and in the winter with
complete lack of rain and lack of water
it's amazing but we have lack of water
in the rainforest
we don't have uh
water we don't have uh clean air without
the forest the forest hold
the the
land in its place
but when you have a president who
doesn't seem to care about this
that must make it very difficult we feel
like this person
doesn't belong here you know
as if he was sent by someone else
he's working for other people not for us
when it comes to
climate change he doesn't represent the
brazilian people no
no definitely not now
so when you
see
in the amazon what is happening what do
you feel in your heart
man if they know how hard it is to
restore
how costly
and to carry to grow up
as a seedling to put it in place to
study to know the right tree to where it
goes have the right species and the time
it takes it's ears this forest like it's
200 years old
to get at this stage
no in the amazon i think they they are
just used to see forest and the people
go there with uh the people who the
forest they go there with other
economic
reasons to grow cattle they they really
don't care but
we have to restore it if we want to
survive and then we to cost a lot of
money
scientists agree on the need to save
these forests in brazil right now it is
the political will that's missing